big day for the markets big day for oil
big day for this country and this
invasion of ukraine does banning russian
imports at this point
have any impact on vladimir putin and
his next moves
oh
i i don't think so particularly it's
perhaps more symbolic
you're talking about
um
200 000 barrels a day it's not nothing
that would be refined for gasoline
purposes the rest of it would be for
distillates look i think it's a good
idea
anything that can reduce cash flow going
to putin and his war machine is a good
thing okay it's a good thing i wish we
had done it
quite some time ago to be honest with
you um the trouble i had with the
announcement was
he took shots at the oil and gas
industry no price gouging no excess
profits what he should be doing and he's
going to texas he could do it today but
he's not is meeting with all the fossil
fuel people it's the greatest industry
in this country it's the greatest
industry around the world and asking
them to turn the spigots on full hog
as soon as possible and say he will
cooperate by reducing these regulatory
barriers that are spread across the
government and by the way if you even
listen to the oil and gas industry they
will very clearly and happily explain to
you how they were able to drill more
cleanly today than ever before in this
country larry we had someone who
is a very good representative of the oil
business her family big intuit she works
for a big oil producing company out of
new mexico biggest in the state and new
mexico is one of the biggest producers
in the country
asked her point blank why is it that the
white house continues to tout 9 000 oil
leases
untapped she said it was disingenuous at
best that they keep touting this listen
we also have the same issues that are
facing every other industry today we
have the same supply shortages and we
have labor shortages so one we can't
find the people that we need to be able
to man up a drilling rag and two we
can't even find things like steel casing
which is what protects the groundwater
when we drill for this oil so
i really i think what the white house is
saying is
is disingenuous at best and by the way
to suggest that the the oil industry
somehow is just choosing not to benefit
from 130
barrels would be pretty hard to believe
but yeah well that's market forces by
the way
if biden had any class at all he would
have thanked the oil industry for
self-sanctioning most of them have
already closed down trading and
financing and refining okay including
the big big guys like exxon mobil and bp
and and even shell which did some
business with it and then had a bad
reaction and
they put they came around that's exactly
right and i'll bet you conoco is going
to come soon too
this leasing thing is a complete red
herring i mean actually normally you'd
have about 40 000 leases outstanding but
that doesn't matter because they need
permits for actual sales
for actual drilling and for actual
pipelining and the whole story here is
they're not getting any applications
through the interior department is
stopping them that's right the energy
department is stopping them the epa is
stopping them and of course they're
under assault from the sec and the
federal reserve not to make loans to all
kinds this is a really important point
and i think we're drilling down on this
more than people have chosen to because
it's it's
you get pretty much into the weeds in
the oil business but one of my sources
also explained to me and i had my brain
room dig this up last night that under
the trump administration while you were
while you were there larry there was far
less leases untapped it was it was in
the 5 000 plus range okay but the reason
why the numbers run up to 9000 is
because there was a rush to get leases
for fear of an administration launching
war on fossil fuels so that's why that
number's so bad that's a good point i
know i like that point but i say
historically
you have even larger numbers of leases
but you know they have to look at
when they when they take a lease out on
land whether it's federal or private
first of all they've got to see if
there's any oil and gas in it amen
that's very important and then second of
all unfortunately they have to get
permits from the authorities so that's
the epa that's the interior department
that's the energy department the point
is not a single sale
on shore or offshore has happened in the
byte administration not one single sale
interior was going to open up a sale and
then a left-wing judge stopped it and
now they're in courts and the byte
administration has not appealed that is
what they tell me they fear that that
could happen at any point even if they
take on the huge expense of tapping into
one that's exactly right i mean the
assault on fossil fuels from day one
with the keystone pipeline has thrown a
wet blanket over the whole industry so
they're afraid to make long-term
investments okay and you know they're
managing their i know you have one other
big point you want to make before you go
because we're running out of time well i
just want to say that um one reason the
stock market rallied earlier was an
announcement from an abc news interview
this is from zielenski i believe he was
interviewed by david muir um ukraine
will no longer seek right now nato
membership
that's a very big thing and that kind of
pulls the rug out from a lot of the
western rationality here i mean it it's
i find it him moving backwards i find it
unseemly to the point of annoying
because we've argued from day one not
day one but biden finally got around to
it that
we were trying to preserve their
sovereignty but also their freedom to
choose
democracy or you know putin
and
if he's saying they're going to give up
aspirations to get into nato then you
have to ask yourself
why are we fighting now he may fight for
his sovereignty okay but that's only
part of the story as far as we're
concerned so i found this very troubling
much as i admire zolensky and his
courage and he's been a great figure
churchillian figures some people say
this is kind of a semi surrender i don't
think it's going to stop putin in the
short run but it may actually encourage
putin who says he's got zielinski on the
run so i don't understand this point at
all and like i say stock market traders
actually bought the market on news we
noticed it's positive now yeah yeah they
thought maybe you know this would be a
shorter end to it i i don't want making
predictions i'm just saying how
surprised i was that silence made this
comment he also said by the way
the donbass region that putin wants of
course zelinski said we can discuss and
find the compromise on how these
territories will live on so that's a
suggestion that you know what i would
say is total sovereignty in the ukraine
maybe off the board and only partial
sovereignty so this is slippage on mr
zielinski's part uh maybe he feels he
has to do that i'm not here to criticize
him i'm just saying the statements like
that change the game to some extent we
should keep an eye on it very
interesting we'll learn more when we
watch you four o'clock on the fox
business network kudlow thank you very
much larry for joining us hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else